[Musique]
bienvenue à sans filtre le podcast où on
parle de ce qu'on veut nous inviter date
cette super chic entre dom plein cette
semaine au podcast
on reçoit rose marie peyrot jeune
actrice avec le vent dans les voiles
incroyable on voit de plus en plus
partout ces temps ci on peut la voir
dans la série le monstre série inspirée
du livre d ingrid falaise qui raconte
l'histoire son histoire de violence
conjugale également dans le film tous
les maux en ce moment le film avant
qu'on explose
une comédie jeunesse loufoque mais
existentielle alors une actrice que
comme je dis que le vent dans les voiles
couvrent de plus en plus au cinéma qui a
également fait partie du film les faux
tatouages qui était réalisé pas mon
frère pascal plante alors on a parlé de
6 janvier pour réel ses projets de sony
parle beaucoup de cinéma
un petit peu de des crises de la
vingtaine la trentaine aussi on en a
parlé de ces chacun en e10 ou est-ce
qu'on en était avec ce qui est une belle
rencontre fixe pas intelligent ben spies
intéressante belle comédienne qui est
que vous allez voir de plus en plus
l'impression que c'est pas c'est pas la
fin de sa carrière
si vous voulez nous encourager avec le
sans fil de podcasts vous pouvez vous
diriger vers une page pétrone on met du
contenu exclusif sur notre page on met
les podcasts en primeur peut même poser
vos questions aux invités
selon la meilleure façon d'encourager ce
comme une communauté qu'on construit
puis qu'on va être rendu à saint patron
carole et qui approche quand même on
essaie de faire un get together avec
tout le monde pour pour se rapprocher
nos fans en fait c'est vraiment la
conversation que qu'on veut ouvrir avec
le public du sans filtre pour ce soit le
plus interactive possible sinon
abonnez-vous à notre chaîne youtube
parce que on va continuer à sortir du
contenu à chaque semaine c'est vraiment
l'âme en cela la mission qu'on s'est
donné en commençant le sans-fil podcast
est de continuer à faire des podcasts
avec des personnes de tous les milieux
puisqu'on va continuer à faire donc
abonnez-vous commenté sur la vidéo puis
à profiter de cette conversation
vraiment enrichissante et posé qu'ont
eue avec rosemary donc bonne écoute bon
bah caste
[Musique]
cool
les a bien travaillé bien maison merci
aux tags nous merci nous recevons c'est
super cool tu es notre première
comédienne soit pas cautionner une belle
façon de commencer avec la comédienne
principale du film de pascale belle
preuve
oui mais au tatouage excès quand ça fait
deux ans ça fait 1 une bonne année qui
sortit moi je suis fier qu'on le tourne
et ça doit faire un an et demi un peu
plus nos mots
le mans comment est-ce que tu as ta vie
inchangé par rapport à avant de
commencer à tourner ce jusqu'à
maintenant parce que en tant que
maintenant tout faux le projet de la fas
premièrement ce n'est seulement que
c'est ce fait mieux que tout changé pour
beaucoup je pense en fait j'avais fait
quelques projets avant de faire les faux
tatouages mais plus je dire si j'avais
fait des shows comme un rupture 30j qui
sont peut-être pas notre public à nous
ben on n'est peut-être pas le public
pour ses shows le nécessairement c'est
peut-être je dirais plus des madame des
mois rue s'est pas non plus
nécessairement public et d'amateurs de
films de répertoire nécessairement 10 le
mode faudrait que les faux tatouages ça
a été mais c'est mon problème c'était
mon deuxième long oui j'avais quand même
un bon rôle là-dedans ok on dirait qu
est ce qu affirme aussi qu'il est
vraiment été bien reçu par le public et
il est le fait d'avoir cette
reconnaissance là un peu dans les
notices ferland même temps c'était je
sais pas ça me fait ça mais je pensais
me donner beaucoup de pain pour moi de
confiance puis aussi de crédibilité
peut-être valises nomination si au prix
comment s'appelle maintenant le ballon
c'est la gare à québec cinéma pour la
vraie révélation de l'année puis juste
récemment il ya un truc l'espèce demain
d'équivalence mais canadienne ces
canadiens screen
faites un essai voilà juste pas autant
cool ces films-là fait le tour c'était
incroyable commencer le voyage et de ces
pays même et pascal est le premier
surpris de voir à quel point à hawaï et
ayez été acceptés tous les festivals
piqué qui a fait le succès lui est fier
de son film des comptes armes etc
créateurs souvent titre c'est toujours
la perfection tout c'est un petit petit
visage pour les prochains peut faire
mieux mais c'est bien reçu sa vison
firme est peut-être et confirmé que ses
conditions étaient bonnes
ton idée était bonne les gens ont
compris ce que tout laisse que tu le dis
oui c'est pascal s'intégrer qui fait des
films de manière toujours un peu
expérimentale mais deux séries phares
d'improvisation il fait faute il sort un
peu des deux sa manière et avec une
différence mais ton avec d'autres états
chacun travaille différemment mais parce
qu'il laisse beaucoup de liberté parce
que ouais ouais vraiment mais pas par
l'improvisation je sais que les règles
d'un acteur tout à fait avec la petite
fille léonie dans le film aussi c'est
une manière différente de travailler
puis je le trouve intelligent qui est
d'avoir cette manière parce que c'est
vrai que tu peux très bien qu'une petite
fille de six ans dans la manière que ce
travail qui est humain et qui tête
géante que je trouvais qu'ils et qui
faisait preuve justement d'ingéniosité
maintenant pour pour l pied mais pin
outils au contraire on est tellement les
gens pensent qu'on a beaucoup improvisé
mais pas tellement dans le fond parce
que les le scénario était était déjà
bien écrit qui étaient déjà écrits comme
des jeunes des écrits comme pascal par
l'art de mixer
quand tu le connais tu vois dans les
conversations notamment touba oui la
dame à la première conversation
un qui parle de belles assiettes ce
mélomane passionné les modes de culture
factice est ce que ça va faire parler un
peu ses personnages à travers lui
québec areq y en a d'autres qui le font
tarantino faso tout le temps oui oui
c'est à son image beaucoup la représente
oui oui mais en tout cas ça s'était très
bien rendus puis félicitations bat
douchez je t'ai vu à la première mais on
sait pas parler je pense oui mes
félicitations c'est vraiment forte
performance puis merci c'est cool
les personnages féminins de même si
c'est qu'il n'a pas autant que si elle
oui c'est le personnage principal 10 ans
et celui d'anthony mais en même temps
elle c'est pas juste un faire valoir et
sonorités sable en tant que fait que je
trouve ça l'fun d'avoir à défendre si ça
c'est pas ça arrive beaucoup plus
souvent des garçons je pense qu'elle est
fille malheureusement ces éclats puis
après ce mois j'ai vu une de denys
arcand
oui dans quel rôle ce faisant c'est
pascal c'est un open commun mais on
s'entend que l'énergique ans est une
légende du cinéma
oui c'est quand même impressionnant qui
quant à eux mettons ces cas là pour
faire sur hold up
qu'est-ce-qui qu'est ce qui passe par
tata et à ce moment là en fait moi
j'avais auditionné pour faire le
personnage principal est qu'il l'ait
interprété par les firmes auraient ils
savaient pas marché et puis en fait à ce
moment là j'avais je m'étais dias et la
perdition de ma vie j'avais vraiment été
déçu denys arcand était pas l'audition
mais j'ai sorti de la piste de ce
personnage là vraiment est plus vieux
que moi quand même puisque hockey avec
tout ce qu'elle a de d2 sensuelle et de
deschacht morts puis j'étais comme
j'étais plus
je reste dans ma vie qui ne s'appelle
pas que factice âge étaient ressorties
un peu déçu de moi puis finalement j'ai
bon je n'ai pas eu et des mois plus tard
mon agence média tard une autre audition
pour le même projet pour une autre
personnage plages et les saints
notamment sait pas que c'est la même
chose mais c'est aussi une fille qui
dégage beaucoup de sensualité je pense
dans une antique au fait que j'ai je
vais à l'audition il a mis beaucoup de
maquillage mais je suis pressé de me
croire mais de convaincre toi-même
convaincre les autres et puis je pensais
pas l'avoir non plus finalement j'ai eu
l'appel comme quand ça marche et puis
baptiste ces denières quand les sessions
dire que j'ai juste g batterie peut un
peu en apprenant ça parce que c'est
beaucoup de pression pitch ses parents
mais en même temps ça a été vraiment un
des plateaux les plus est très relax
mais quand on dirait que ça paraît que
j'ai fait ça toute sa vie puis le lui pu
tellement stressée été hissé ce qui fait
ici comment gérer une équipe sans être
un tortionnaire derrière tout le monde
qui est fait qu'ils étaient vraiment
c'était très cool
ouais puis la direction d'acteurs petit
ce qu'est ce qu'une différence entre
l'auteur d'expérience comme ce versus
d'autres mais finalement ça est-ce que
tu savais ton espèce de deux pots de
l'expérience les dents je dirais plus
dans son cas dans sa façon de gérer le
plateau même si ça paraît que ça ça
paraît que ça fait longtemps qu'il fait
ce puits que ici comment comment faire
pour travailler avec les gens puis pour
pour faire ça dans le calme réalisateur
je pense que ça prenne ça tellement à
coeur que ça peut devenir le monde est
un peu ripart par la présence dudit
réalisateur dit non mais lui je reste
d'une façon très humaine je trouvais
histoire j'avais vraiment 2% donc mais
en fait c'est drôle parce que tiersen ou
est-ce que je joue ce dauphin le golf le
vent du golf et du mccc calmes sur le
green
dit comme ça c'est rock est bâti sur un
terrain de golf mais c'est c'est un
green de pratique c'est un petit pot du
criquet nos bleus non c'est du patch
potec important et si tu veux dire
qu'aucun cas montré à côté de l'hôtel
douce et l oeil avec pierre curie à côté
on a parlé de ce québec 32 coups c'était
vraiment quelque chose
c'est un peu aussi dans leurs dénis
arcand a souvent fait de juxtaposition
le genre de l'intellectuel puis avec la
les choses les plus banales ou des fois
base la ville
oui dans des graines empire américain
qui ce fait justement un creuset où
nommer en parlant de l'an mil c'est
vraiment comme c'est lé plus beau
une potée et puis parler de cemex et les
transpose vraiment ça son heure dans sa
vie c'est pas le contraire ces derniers
sa création dans la vie de tous les
jours de créer des situations comme ça
oui mais on a des excuses à une analyse
qui ont lieu notamment la semaine passée
avec et avec l'auberge et unisys et pis
vu son expérience lui a joué d'un cheval
serpent yves c puis c'était justement
l'ambiance des plateaux plutôt raide le
trépied hockey parce que apparemment
c'était qu'il réalisateur ben en fait
c'est sûrement famille c'est archambault
le métier ça a sorti le quai comme il
n'était pas toujours le sujet justement
il ya des réalisateurs que leur approche
c'est super par rohff puis que c'est
comme ceux qui veulent le signe à sortir
le meilleur de mon piano d'autre que
l'émeute ont justement pascal la presse
le club le plus doux pascal ce sujet est
une technique des parents de soupe c'est
je comprends pas un vêtement de l'ailé
modérée hazard qui font ces gens n'aient
déjà côtoyé ou devait rencontrer sur des
plateaux plancher on dirait que c'est
pas la bonne façon d'arriver à ses fins
je t'aime que pour certaines personnes
ça marche mais c'est un acte anti
dispose est elle capable de jouer
piquant que la caméra tourne bientôt
personnage de penser que faute instaure
un climat même en dehors de la cam ou de
sujets andry que peut-être que pour des
non professionnels peut plus marcher
mais en même temps mais vous savez rien
fait sinon ça peut devenir malsain je
pense bien pu facilement devenir masse
ouais quand même des acteurs déjà qui au
cinéma je pense que l'acteur est ici
mais peut se sentir et facilement pantin
de la vision d'un autre l'asie si
l'autre ne ne fait pas bien son job ne
lui fait pas confiance ou justement de
pascal plancque qui font tellement
confiance ben dhia ils m'ont choisi
parce qu'il sait que le personnage puis
parce qu'il sait que je suis a été le
gérant depuis que j'ai une pensée
derrière toi on travaille c'est puis le
temps l'interprète mais tu es un artiste
ou si c'est pour donner une partie
créative c'est le minimum c'est vraiment
juste est ce fait secondes dit fais ci
fais ça pour son côté est exact un peu
le parallèle un peu on en parlait
on a fait on a fait un podcast juste
pour nous les membres de notre pétrole
puis en parler de donjons dragons aussi
des familles à ces gens un jeu de
tableau ce que chaque personnage a un
rôle puis un quelqu'un qui écrit une
histoire ensemble tout le monde décrit
ce toit parce que le le mode de jeu il
connaît pas qu'est ce qui sépare les
personnages vont ensemble ils écrivent
une histoire tandis que chaque
personnage qu'on est mieux que le maître
de jeu leur personnage dit quand tu
laisses la place je pense aux acteurs
quand est un réalisateur qui laisse la
place aux acteurs faisant confiance aux
filles qui connaissent leurs personnes
âgées qui sont leurs personnages c'est
que son gamin de l'intégrer dès que ça
peut laisser des laissé paraître des
éclats que le réalisateur popu ensemble
créé un espèce de truc qui est au dessus
du plan initial point telle impression
et parlement qui est aussi des
réalisateurs qui tiennent mordicus à
l'antarctique il veut juste un acteur
qui capable de fort hare de jouer ce que
celle du film aussi plein les yeux plein
de variables qui rentrent en ligne de
compte
un film plus sur des relations justement
soit 10 des personnages complexes pi
s'est fait avant il faut maintenant que
dernier au quai ouest soit puis
c'est le meilleur exemple les auteurs et
les deux acteurs principaux qui
construit comme strasbourg qui chaque
mois son père le réalisateur ou steak
rdc je veux pas je vais pas dire quelque
chose qui est pas la vérité en effet son
nom sur le bout de la lancer lequel elle
s'est beaucoup du cirque et les rires
oui je pense que c'est exactement ça
mais tellement de place que même les
deuxième et troisième films sont
carrément écrite et où scénario les
acteurs vie que
pitié c'est tellement bien fait cfm le
donjon pour ceux qui nous écoutent qui
connaissent paul c'était une trilogie
les trois films qui ont été faites
chacun à 7 ans d'intervalle avec d'un
premier film un couple de deux personnes
qui se rencontrent
sept ans plus tard où sont rendus cette
amp top ils ont vraiment été fait à ce
intervalles qui met les visages sont
tellement complexes tellement et
notamment profondeur que des fois des
actions des petites idées politiques que
tu vois d'un film à l'eau tout mais
vraiment c'est ultra bien fait et pour
voir une chimie en deux personnages je
voi po meilleure marque la sq que ces
films je pense que c'était une des
inspirations grosses installations pour
pascal ce soit s'est félicité des films
magistrat j'adore quand même oui c'est
ça c'est tout dans l'improvisation et
film je pense que beaucoup d répète
aussi c'est toi c'est pas tous les
lillois tous les plateaux où tout est
luxe de pouvoir répétés non c'est ça oui
mais pas le réalisateur je pense que
c'est tellement ce qui veut qui cherche
quand même pas à répéter ou à trouver
plus loin des commandes à 38,6 sauf que
ça va être ça non mais on le sent
qu'elle est que les acteurs ont
participé une session sent que ça vient
beaucoup de zones de films à tort syrien
nascar fragile comme ça que sa peur
parce que j'aurais coulé après pu lui
s'il fait des répètes des fois six mois
de répète en tournée sans fin comme
comme si monter une petite erreur
commenté pour que chacun sait vraiment
ça soit comme pu l'apprécier arrivent
les caméras au pis on shoote sommes à
tilloy charlebois de mai mais s'est
satisfait répéter répéter répéter pour
qu'ils aient vraiment ça soit la chimie
soit gouaoui parfait mais j'ai tourné
avec micheline lanctôt c'était puis elle
a nous a dit au début on a comme une
rencontre avec micheline puis
une actrice qui s'appelle gabrielle
lazure mère dans le film qui a voulu
qu'on se rend compte que les trois ans
de tournée
yan zi bon là on veut jaser d'un peu des
personnages là mais on fera pas de
répéteront je vais pas vous dire voici
six votre personnage est comme ça vous
êtes choisis parce que je vous fais
confiance puis parce que je sais que
vous allez trouver votre personnage ou
même un peu las de la tournée les
clichés dans tout ça mais sécuriser un
peu parce que c'est un autre monument
maintenant je m'attendais à ce qu'elle y
répète car mon stress ou kengen un peu
plus là demain non non non c'était
vraiment comme beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup de confiance qui a été misé en
premier motif qu'il faut comme le
prendre faire comme à qui je vais être
capable mais en même temps à être moi et
édité j'imagine que c'est grâce around
the j 4 électorat aussi parce que quand
il filme des pilotes a pas de feedback
huileuse téléphone de sa fille
on la refait on trouve des ressources en
soi mais d'ailleurs d'ailleurs ça
m'impressionne justement les cas passés
d'un acteur de de trouver en soit la
manière de se mettre dans la peau d'un
autre
parce que je veux prendre le pouls de
tout véhicule comme finir comme
expérience pilote décide de comprendre
c'est que la réalité de cette personne
aux deux personnes lors il des choses
qui étaient avec un background qui pour
le nord c'est sert cabaye handicap à
l'autre puis plus on s'éloigne de nous
même plus
teddy des comédiens qui métamorphose de
méconnaissance de la femme des rôles
sont plus le fun que d'autres gangs of
new york qui joue le beau tchéquie qui
ment schosteck but d'aider des acteurs
comme ceux qui sont connus au
principalement pour pour être des
méthodes actives au québec chez ses
parents je suis tout c'est dans la
manière de faire tant que ceo québec -
pourrait peut-être le dire parce que moi
mais ben ça peut être un peu je pense ça
pourrait être vu tes au québec on est on
est une plus petite industrie avec moins
de moyens et puis on est tous y ait des
gens qui questionnent pas trop prendre
de place on est pas des les acteurs
c'est des gens généralement accessible
qu'on voit des émissions pics en jeu le
personnage tout le temps jusqu'à l'été
pour qu'ils ont joué
ah ça tourne après ce n'est plus du tout
tu te tue des méthodes particulières
quand même temps on donne un personnage
c'est quoi ton cheminement jusqu'au
moment de jouer le titre tutu l'intègre
j'imagine ce bain gib
si je relis scénario beaucoup beaucoup
de fois on dirait que c'est comme s'il
était dans la base de tout casser si ton
premier contact avec le projet et puis
j'essaie de lire aussi non d'un
environnement qui la première fois que
je viens projet c'est tellement excitant
aussi recevoir un scénario que j'ai
choisi le moment il a eu du bon dire et
puis souvent jeu ça m'arrive aussi de
vraiment écrire de me bâtir une histoire
dans ma tête me tant que parce que des
fois tu as plein d'informations sur le
background des personnages des fois tu
en mets tellement peu mais mais faut que
tu peux tu le trouve je pense acquis
pendant ta tête ou qui avait certains
trucs d'un peu établi de background
peut-être fac dix fois j'aime bien comme
écrire ce que je m'imagine du personnage
avant qu'est-ce-qui ccc qui sa mère jean
pied non des skis et les hippies juste
pourra pour que moi ça se déposent
quelque part à l'intérieur de moi qui
peut-être que ça veut rien changer à mon
interprétation mais peut-être que ça va
ajouter une petite subtilité quelque
part dans une réplique tu veux que je te
dirais que ça dépend si c'est ça ça
dépend du personnage puis du réalisateur
avec qui je travaille pipe
j'ai pas de méthode claire mais je n'en
jeu l'aja développe encore et encore au
début ta carrière c'est un accord pour l
aspect mieux ton ton nom oui c'était ma
façon très sains
mais pas pour venir à ma ce que je
disais tantôt le les capacités du
giessen à peau d'un autre fou pour toi
ce qui est est alerte et c'est
d'observer ou de magasiner ou de
regarder des films je sais pas trop pour
avoir une espèce d'éventail les plus
larges possibles de c'est quoi la vie
humaine en sont quand même
wen non mais c'est sa baisse parce que
c'était impressionnant je trouve que
d'être capable dès crédible dans une
autre partie on est tellement influencée
par notre propre expérience de la vie
on voit à travers nos yeux qui sont peu
tes qui te passe la main une vision du
monde parmi eux 6 millions 9 soit
capable de devoir d'en avoir une autre
ben oui je dirais que je regarde les
films pour voir les acteurs pour voir
leurs propositions mais je regarde aussi
je pense que ce avant même d'être une
cinéphile j'étais quelqu'un qui aime
beaucoup observer la vie en général qui
met pas son psychologue puis on dirait
que c'est un mot beaucoup parlé de tgcom
grandi avec cette conception le 2 2
belle conception le j'ai entendu parler
de psychologie quand même tout dans ma
vie du mapid et des différents types
d'humains puis on dirait que si j'avais
pété comédienne c'est quelque chose qui
m'aurait intéressé puis je pense qu'il
est vraiment un lien parce que quand tu
es content puisque le tue juge pas la
personne qui devant toi tu essayes de
comprendre ces mécanismes essaie de
comprendre qu est ce qu est ce qui donne
sur ce résultat leur fac
quand j'aborde un personnage le fait de
la même façon this si je jouais peu ça
m'est jamais arrivé encore messi jouer
un personnage vraiment je sais pas une
fille est complètement hors d'elle même
et violent tout avec des excès de colère
ou de quelque chose de malsain en elle
il faudrait pas que je la condamne je la
juge je voudrais que je comprenne
pourquoi est comme ça puis elle dans sa
tête et c'est normal d'être comme
c'était là que je pense qu'il faut il
faut comme approché seraient beaucoup
d'ouverture l'opus on n'a pas su
vraiment c'est ce que laisse name of est
aussi je pense du point de vue d'une
qu'elle consomme beaucoup de cinéma je
ne prends que ça aiguise cette empathie
le loin des gens qui sont et qui j'étais
déjà critique ou déjà un peu yen campe
un sourire du monde
j'ai rencontré les comédiens cacher que
je me dis ah mais je pensais tellement
pas que cet humain derrière le comédien
était comme sauter je compte justement
un manque d'empathie ou accus bonne
propension à apprécier l'autre outil qui
juge plus facilement qu'ils cherchent à
comprendre en fait je m'adapte tu peux
pas faire ça comme jobs c'étaient pas
des pins peu empathique
ouais j'ai l'impression ça c'est
vraiment intéressant le parallèle entre
la psychologie pile
acte i parce que vraiment activement en
tant qu'humain et on n'a pas le réflexe
d'essayer de comprendre les réactions
des autres c'est quelque chose qui
souvent nous nous ralentit je pense moi
le premier je suis chauffeur de ce2 de
juger la réaction des gens sensés de
comprendre qui est ce qui a amené à
cette réaction là mais pour être capable
de comprendre les différentes
personnalités les différentes personnes
les différentes façons de réagir à un
événement donné il faut que tu sois
capable de réfléchir à ça je trouve son
parallèle qui vraiment
qui est vraiment pertinent de refaire en
fait cheap pour la psychologie puis dans
d'autres sports comme le ton c'était
quelqu'un qui avait coûté beaucoup le
cinéma étranger les exemples dans sa vie
écouter du cinéma japonais syrien
mexicain wever
parallèlement plus de chance que tu sois
plus que tu ailles moins de propos
racistes quelque chose que jamais eu
accès ça te fait voir justement le monde
à travers leurs yeux puis si tu écoutes
le film sur justement réfugiés réfugiés
fait syrien pardon piste est dure à tête
piquée de voix titre toute sa douleur
son cheminement de ce oui ça ça va être
vraiment mieux à comprendre ces postures
réseau ton pays un entrepôt à voir ce
qu'on prend l'autre côté de la médaille
je peux pas dire ça oui totalement
oui mais même au delà de au delà d'un
film qui traite d'un réfugié
- justin juste une forme d'art qui vient
d'ailleurs pour comprendre
l'unicité de chaque personne en face de
chaque culture puis ça c'est sûr que
c'est ça que les gens mais ton qui ont
des propos extrêmement raciste par
exemple sur le page facebook du journal
de montréal sur aux attentes en nouvelle
zélande
ah oui toi dans l'oil ont retiré leurs
nouvelles de leur famille qui retire la
nouvelle parce que c'était juste des
commentaires disgracieux mais voyant son
exil à huy où c'est la famille syrienne
qui s'est passé ou mais la famille
syrienne qui est décédé dans la salle
c'est pas des gens qui consomment la
culture qui vient d'ailleurs parce que
sûrement pas parce que tu peux pas avoir
des propos comme ceux c'était si tu
comprends que il ya d'autres façons de
voir que la tirer de façon de vivre
quand même type i télé réalité
complètement ça te fait voir des bons
côtés de chacune des cultures parce que
des fois tous le seul la seule chose qui
sera vers nous c'est en attente de
l'état si ceux ci c'est la seule
information topito pas la curiosité ou
l'esprit critique d'aller voir plus loin
c'est ce que tu vas passer
wikimedia sais ce qu'ils te seras en
jean t il c'est dommage mais les films
dont on parlait des films japonais série
mais surtout cinéma du parc au cinéma
beaubien dans une salle
aussi directe de trois-rivières sas
europe malheureusement ça se rend pas
souvent aux gens qui sont plateau mont
royal est en fait que même les salles on
peut dire que c'est en fait les gens
faisaient partie d un film étranger qui
était vraiment poussé par netflix et
rome récemment que le talent et son et
flix piste-là comme la chose qui te
quitte pop et c'est le fun mais
tellement un film qui aurait justement
god qui gangrènent à être vus en salles
point que ça plus de dommages devant le
tchèque istres laptop crouch avec un
sommaire dit juste je voulais le voir en
salle au cinéma moderne puis pendant une
semaine je pensais comme juste après le
jour de l'an pendant deux semaines y
avait plus de billets du tout comment
faut que j'explique mojix netflix gt4
netflix qui justifie j'ai aimé sûr mais
si comme c'est un film que je pense que
le vif d'un en gelée par nul autre que
c'est un film qui il faut être patient
c'est mieux que le fameux l'art c'est un
film que pendant une bonne partie du
film justement ça prépare à ce qui va
arriver puis comme une ou deux scènes
vraiment climax wes cates est
complètement bouleversée qui tout le
fait ma préparation mais quand tu es un
clic de l'asie qui peut être facilement
belgique un puceau facebook avait monté
les français dans une salle tu vas être
plus concentré c'est un poil moins
discret qui était ton exemple m'ont ému
marc antoine marc antoine tanguay coûte
quand même pas mal de films qu'ils
aiment le genre est après 30 minutes 5
et c'est dommage parce qu'il passe à
côté de quelque chose il ya passé à côté
d'une expérience qu'il l'aurait
peut-être marketé qu'il allait peut-être
il rêve eu de quoi qui que jamais
expérimentée parce que c'est un des
films et téléfilms peuple
qui messi sera dans une salle dirais pas
au work out après 30 tours est écouté
puis il y aurait eu justement le pay off
à la fin qu'est le film prêts partez ça
change la manière de consommer le cinéma
beaucoup de sens
oui tout de même de faire j'imagine
j'imagine que on est obligé de faire des
films un peu plus face paye justement
parce que pour garder l'intérêt de mon
départ c'est un film dont tu es le héros
le sait ce qu'il faut de même d'arsenal
ouais c'est ça ben 9 9 oct interagissent
pour que ton personnage prenne et des
soins dans le salle garde comme activé
dans le film mais [ __ ] bonne histoire
c'est un bon film mais faut quand même
que tu interagissent fait que le
principe et c'est comme un peu un libre
et dans un jeu bien où est ce que ça
s'en va pour le web lé ou un destin plus
sentir impliqué je pense à ça risque de
faire un espèce de y qu'ils ont confirmé
qu'ils vont faire d'autre de ce concept
le but arrive tu arrives à un moment
puis là c'est comme telle dès son
édition puis le film prend le moins
inquiet mais tu sais qu'en supprimant y
avait des livres sa part de léguer il
lit un livre au début qui est un livre
dont vous êtes les rapports comme ça
c'est bon ça fonctionnait
le film a en soi c'est plus honnête je
pense le fmi correct mais qui s'adresse
à moi j'ai trouvé
j'ai trouvé que
qu'est-ce qui l'arrêté
mais c'est ça moi je pense que le film
comme je pensais seules fins différentes
pistes intéressantes de capable de
naviguer à travers ce hub de tout tout
checker commun devant les possibilités
c'est soit disant que de voir aussi mais
tant d'un point de vue je te matau d'un
point de vue d'acteurs et d'actrices et
c'est ce serait intéressant aussi parce
que tu joues la même scène mais deux
fois puis les choses parce que la
décision peut être choisis puis ça
revient après tout le temps dans le film
inquiet un drôle d'exercice mais c'est
faux pis une réflexion ça va mieux c'est
comme les phénomènes l'homme qui
m'impressionne tellement de l'effet
papillon qui est justement les gars je
sais pas il peut aller chercher son café
ou au tim hortons matin ben viens
d'arriver je serais curieuse de regarder
juste pour les pc au début à 10,6 à si
elle ne s'est pas passé ces faits se
seraient pas passées comme une espèce de
file de choses se sont passées à cause
calais au matin et pris une décision et
que sa place directe des films les
personnages map ça recommence
et vous ce nom il y avait tant d'années
avec tom cruise soit vraiment jeux vidéo
et edge of tomorrow est quand même bon
là qui sait comme il faut qui sauve la
membres mais genre à chaque fois qui
commence au début à wake est né il ya
une série vraiment à bonn qui est qui
est ce honnête l'extérieur qui est
certes il a pas longtemps sur chantôme
qui s'est un peu sur le concept même si
c'est pour sauver le monde le sait
c'est une fille dans un parti qui me la
morde la revient plus lorsque mais c'est
ma bonne chance de wapiti ces messieurs
c'est plus existentielles le thé c'est
vraiment comme une raison pourquoi ça
arrive le faut car aig un peu des trucs
qui n'ont réglé dans sa vie heureux
qu'ils aient ça devient vraiment
philosophique syrie le premier s'agit
pas de passer derrière le jour des
marmottes mais oui parce que parce qu'il
faut que la marmotte se voit où police
et de bus
c'est pas pour décider de l'hiver c'est
fini c'est fini par mal du tout je pense
ici à voit son ombre il reste deux
semaines soit en a pas de salut que le
long de voies sur des panneaux aux
arrêts d'autobus le monstrueux je me dis
que le suspect reconnaît maintenant
ben oui puis non en fait je pense que si
je vous racontais que j'allais au
saguenay en fin de semaine puis moi je
viens de trois rivières qui les place je
me faire connaître que c'est pas quand
je suis dit non à moriat j'habitais sur
laurier sur le plateau c'est quoi j'ai
l'impression que quand je vais faire mon
épicerie ou que je vais je prends le
métro
peut-être qu'à montréal en fait les gens
sont plus immunisés avec sophie blondy
un seul sens - femmes les dérangent mais
devant la fille du panneau dans le métro
sciences po ou peut-être suis plus une
distance mais en région j'ai
l'impression que ben parce que les
artistes sont plus un mot rien quand je
sais pas mais oui le ça m'est arrivé
quelquefois de me faire connaître mais
je suis peut-être aussi c'est une
théorie que le monde la région consomme
plus
du contenu francophone québécois
proportion way en proportion wen an qui
sont plus proches peut-être de ses plus
de chance que mettons y agit sur 100
personnes et il y en a eu 20 ha oui
c'est ça ouais mais d'ailleurs hier soir
tu vas le regretter qu'un peu la montre
j'écoutais une douce habitude écouter
les six mais ce cochon tout est bon
bravo au travail depuis midi l'acteur
qui fait le monseigneur louis portet
vraiment série le mercy avec brio
vraiment quelque chose des preuves maman
m'a plu ma plus belle ma plus difficile
expérience en même temps de tourner
cette série le mais j'ai un jeu comme je
suis vraiment contente en fait j'espère
que mes en fait quand j'avais tourné la
bolduc débit lynch avait 10e avec du
saumon et puis savez comme un peu
traumatisée elle m'avait dit amo j'ai
comme l'impression que ça va être mon
mon dernier grand rôle ou que mon
dernier grand rôle mais que ça va être
le plus grand rôle que j'aurai jamais eu
à jouer parce qu'elle porte le film sur
ses épaules parce qu est ce parce
qu'elle est à chanter elle est de toutes
les scènes type donc je pense qu'elle
avait quand même un peu le vertige de de
faire comme à pic le rôle de ma vie qui
a quand j'ai tourné des films tournés ça
j'avais comme un peu l'impression que
j'étais juge zippo j'ose croire que non
le mais j'avais un peu le stress de me
dire ah est-ce que ça va être sahara
était seul et le truc le plus complexe
et le plus complet que j'aurais eu à
faire j'espère que non mais qu'est-ce
qui est fois dans une carrière aussi
jeune ouais mais comme il ya des films
qui vont sortir d'avec tournant bientôt
le fait que j'imagine que c'est pas la
fin merci les gars
mais ça doit être ça doit être vraiment
spécial de jouer des scènes aussi
intense aussi violente
même si tu joues le pays même si c est
pas vrai ça doit bouleverser comme un
coin
oui parce qu'en fait c'est là que je me
suis rendu compte aussi que je ne
pensais pas être aussi affecté c'est
quand on tournait une scène parce qu'il
est ou m sort de la douche puis ils
rentrent se fit dans le mur pilet c'est
comme s'ils veulent étrangler la foudre
un appartement t2 maquettes et sa patte
tac bref on pratique cette séquence
l'agent de demi intensité c'est pour
juste coordonner tous les mouvements
puis c'est une leçon très coordonnée ou
si on sait tout le temps notre main
valais ou et pendant peu près combien de
temps arrêté au gym n'a pas peur de
faire cesser la sécurité du fait qu'il
s'est exactement qu'est ce que c'est
juste pour notre sécurité physique mes
improvisations battu mais finalement
c'est en les faisant ou est-ce que là on
y va avec
mettons folle intensité mais médime qui
ne rentrent pas dans le mur non plus à
100% pour vrai métier un genre de 50% ou
haut que lui à la grèce et puis après je
me souviens il ya eu quelques scènes où
les deux on était comme un peu plus
affectée qu'on leur ait cru puis autant
moi de m'être fait brasser que lui
d'avoir comme prince une faillite et
s'épaulent fans de la position avec 5
min de celle du bourreau mais pas que ça
en a fait quelque chose de on a quand
même réalisé aussi l'ampleur de ce film
c'est fini tu sais ce que même que ceux
ci si je sais que ce n'est pas pauvre
esata fait quatre points loin imaginons
les gens comme toi ton cas de tomber en
mode survie n'était en mode vraiment
télécom en est un qui est clair même si
oui c'est même ce trimestre a raison le
sais que c'est pas vrai comme quelque
chose qui vient qui déclenche puisque la
salle est sûrement un peu le faut pas
que tu dis c'est pas vrai c'est pauvre
est taclé de jouer comme ça avec ces
mécanismes peuvent biologique et
émotionnelle puis après tu en reçois
plus de 10 millions mais c'est pas vrai
heureusement que c'est pas vrai mais tu
viens quand même de le vivre ou de
convaincre que tu étais en train de le
vivre activement cette arrivée que je
check après une prise
j'avais besoin d'une bulle saint-jean -
même si j'ai à chaque fois que c'est des
fois je me sentis mal quasiment pour
mehdi parce que j'ai j'avais comme
besoin de m'éloigner physiquement et je
pensais juste normal mais en même temps
ces lieux où si vous avez tourné quand
même temps pour ce est à 35 jours
c'était on a fini on a commencé en
septembre qui ont déterminé on est allé
tourner en afrique jusqu'à la
mi-novembre des tournages extrêmement
intense expérience
ouais oui pis si c'était la première
fois que j'avais un un premier d'un
personnage principal dans le fond fait
que j'étais de de toutes les scènes de
toutes les journées mais c'est aussi le
fun tv comme le tout le temps là avec
l'équipe technique d'andré que ça crée
aussi des liens que j'avais pas
rencontre j'avais peu connus ou dans les
autres plateau au dessus des longues
journées sur 3 me tromper dans le
continuer à être ensemble c'est logique
on était tout le temps ensemble qui est
non j'ai je suis chanceuse c'est très
cool comment s'est passé le processus
pour ce rôle et mission début comme
comme une autre mais dès le début on
sentait que que la série allait tirer du
canada l'annoncé comme étant une grosse
et richard j'ai vu que ces histoires
vraies en plus il ya comme pas mal de
dents jeu en fait dans tout ça et bonne
raison que ce soit vu aussi l'exact
c'est ça je pense que la série avait
commencé à être fêté comme un projet en
même temps que fugueuse ou un parent
fugueuse pluies ont vu le succès de
figure avec ce sont 10 à notre projet
c'est spa expo pareil mais il ya quelque
chose
des parades à la forme exacte ses
habitudes là qu'ils rentraient qu'on
sentait que ça allait quand même bing
qui s'essaye trois auditions puis à
manifester je peux jouer dans une drôle
drôle de semaine factuel dans un chalet
tout seul pendant deux semaines pied on
a gentiment appelé en criant vraiment
contente de me dire que j'avais le rôle
de mêlée mais ça ça fait comme je
répondrais j'ai senti que les que le
stress et la pression qui j'étais
contente mais en même temps j'ai ces
stec
je savais que j'allais devoir travailler
fort puis s'est beaucoup de consulter le
personnage principal voudrais que tu dis
que si c'est pas bon ça va tu de ta
faute
bach et folk échanges sont plus que je
sèche à ce matin ce qui va peut-être
parce que ça en tête
peut-être une pression comme il en
existe peu cool d'être aussi parce que
depuis qu'on est jeune
quand on parle de film on parle rarement
de films de séries on parle rarement du
réalisateur ouais candidature seul
dernier avec brad pitt
oui c'est là notre espace il porte le
film où le projet sur ses épaules
souvent oui oui exagérant les faits - ce
qui on a pas vraiment certain réalisme
aussi le délateur qui fait comme un peu
la promotion détruire un peu cette fois
les acteurs qui sera vendre des films
caisse quand même mal real qui se
croient possible
c'est un film dans l'univers de batman
avec jamel et all away
quan est élu il apparaît même chose de
bon le chapiteau est sorti sur les
médias sociaux pour dire à mes sorties
il y avait tourné huit heures de contenu
piller comme la bande en trois minutes
et demie il s'était fait dire ça te fait
marty stx avait vraiment quelque chose
de vraiment cessé syrien conquis qu'avec
un réal un peuple et son odeur qui ont
mis le ponton pour proches et mes
sorties à la journée après lancement lui
ai pas vu le film qui a vu le film
médias les powers quand il ya tellement
mis d'accord il lui avait été mis dans
son rôle de thil s'était dit lui jouer
le joker ok je te dis je veux pas
refaire comme hitler jeu a effectué le
step était vraiment au lycée après cette
personnification du joker leur faut que
tu en fasses une autre complètement
différentes sinon tu vas te faire
comparer sur soi faire comparer toute
façon fait qu'il veut faire de quoi sa
cage et amis vraiment d'énergie là
dedans ils ont tourné huit heures de
footage il va en trouver
c'est ce qui tend goesele d'acteur c'est
que des fois des bons acteurs avec un
mauvais real lyon de leur mauvais ou un
mauvais scénario aussi dire est pas
naturelle week est la phrase il opte
échos mais qu'est ce que je vais faire
de ça la change un peu non non non non
je tiens aussi bon je te mettais les
séries qui sont des pme de madère le tai
chi poké qui en régissent
d'effectivement les problèmes de la vie
quotidienne mais qu'il faut qu'ils
tournent à l'infâme de boletin de phares
15,8 pas le temps
au niveau du scénario tout pas le temps
d'écrire
quatorze draft dans les eaux faut que ça
sorte avec souvent c'est comme une
phrase qui est l'up l'acteur kg 2 take
pour essayer de dire ce serait le mieux
placé pour faire juger logique tourner
une en affaires que même série s'appelle
clash qui est une quotidienne plus
jeunesse qui est tellement de côté le
positif at on une quotidienne mais aussi
ses coups très négatif où justement ces
mêmes pour tout le monde
le réalisateur a peu de temps l'acteur
reprend l'auteur comme ceux dits les
scénarios comme ses six buts et si les
machines sont enfermés chez eux puis
c'est comme juste pont d'un épisode à
chaque jour sa base sans qualités je
sais pas parce que une stricte intérieur
mat on thin s'est tournée cette façon le
pis si une des séries les plus les plus
regardées mort mais clairement que c'est
comme un genre de marathon est inquiet
car le temps est restreint sur un
plateau sur la tête tellement c'est
l'espèce de stress c'est juste moi
mettons quand je suis derrière minutes
puis qui georges gillett des affaires à
faire un peu de temps georges devient ce
triple jeu édité par pays oui puisque
sur ses études en cinéma tu peux finir
non en retard ça arrive plus souvent
direction des quotidiennes va nous
montrer comment je les virus et on
finissait à cette arme est avec un
quinze minutes de jeu mais papa de bonne
demi-heure s'est rendu le tout le monde
est un peu déçu c'est le directeur photo
qui a pas sa shot la comédienne qui qui
a pas le temps d'en faire une autre qui
par temps de faire une autre prise mais
je pense que je pense que les
producteurs voient qui
on est capable quand même pas que pour
ceux que les formes en reste mais j'ai
su me niang n'est pas toujours le temps
de plus ce qui serait arrivé
les vans yonhap que manie de mettre une
contrainte sa force à la la oui oui
créativité sociale aux pêcheurs plein
plateau de cinéma ça doit être très
stressant souvent notamment respecter
les budgets respecter l'ordre et
respectueux de ce micro il aussi bien à
l'eau aa je pense qu'il courait
alors oui en fait
je marche ça marche et c'est ça parce
qu'il ya beaucoup de contraintes
monétaires qui rentrent dans le six mois
c'est dispendieux excès le temps le
temps c'est de l'argent
d'une certaine façon c'est petit dépasse
du nord je sais pas c'est quoi en terme
de budget le aucune idée mais
visiblement on se dépasse du nord est
quelqu'un qui se précipitent fait que
moral ok mais s'attendent pas à ce que
demain on finit à la banque d'europe c1
où je suis autant est calculée voilà
mais j'avais j'avais été sur des
plateaux à pascal c'est maintenant de
ses premiers courts métrages primés
c'était l'extase real doit qui les ont
exposés grande at elle plante le gogo
d'europe oui ça prend quelqu'un comme ça
parce que souvent le gal zakari parti
dans ses rangs du monde qui touche la
belgique tchèque leur a piqué le thé
tient en ce moment tu tu disais tantôt
que tu aimes cours en promo
le taux plein projets qui s'en viennent
on lit nombreux tantôt pour ceux qui
veulent le monde bien sûr ce qui avant
d'exploser
[Rires]
oui vous allez voir c'est vraiment bon
pour vrai c'est un genre de film d'ados
jeu direct et je pense que le public
cible c'est peut-être les ados en même
temps vraiment intelligent avec un
humour absurde qui va plaire à à des
générations plus depuis lundi non plus
mais je pense que c'est dans l'humour en
tout cas c'est quelque chose qui peut
nous parler puis non je suis vraiment
vraiment fier de ce fameux you this
point à vos marques party la saa fois on
n'est pas là dedans lancé
c'est un vrai contenu des gens pour pour
des jeunes pieds ex l'histoire d'un gars
d'un fossile la 3ème guerre mondiale
arrive on va tous crever avec il faut
perdre sa virginité
ces séances demain c'est ça qui est qui
a pas encore fait la pompe estime que je
peux pas mourir mourir comme ça
non voilà qui est une réaction tout à
fait
avec des thèmes aussi ses contraintes
legault au site est très anxieux à
l'idée de mourir tout seul ça amène des
gens des questions existentielles aussi
qu'on compte quand on a 16 17 ans et
puis convient peut-être peut-être plus
de gravité ou que c'est étienne galloise
il y ait un dialogue qui va tourner son
premier long 6 et bientôt sur une équipe
de jeunes des nouveaux projets c'est lui
qu'il croit l'équipe qui joue pis les
vôtres nous attend ce exact je viens à
shenyang les microbes j'ai le même le
même le même argent qu'elle ait faute at
war et qu'on est cool cool coup moins un
fait qui est en jeu c'est je suis pas
fier de voir l'évolution de ce mois une
nouvelle vague de personnes qui rentrent
dans le dans l'industrie du film au
québec je crois que c'est bon on le voit
de plus en plus le toit nouveaux
réacteurs dfm des nouveaux acteurs qui
viennent un peu brisé l'espèce de
monopole oui les acteurs et à rio j'ai
l'impression aussi tu es au niveau des
subventions on donne aux artistes j'ai
l'impression qu'il ya beaucoup de
subventions qui vont dans des projets
pour la relève aussi way qui est une
bonne affaire
trop souvent c'était les mêmes personnes
qui tu es juste je pense qu'elle est
maintenant les faux tatouages c'est
peut-être un jeu c'est pas le micro
budget avant ça ressemble à quoi mais on
dirait que depuis les faux tatouages
mais je pense que ça prouve aussi que
les jeunes avec beaucoup d'argent sont
capables de faire des choses que je lui
dirai pas monstres aux lancers sur
s'affaiblit pourtant il est allé à
berlin quand même des films qui ont des
millions t en terme de budget fac
tant mieux si les institutions se
rendent compte que que ce qui est
vraiment du potentiel à l'international
c'est des films qui sont autant de
qualités que que ce deux dernières
campagnes
honnêtement que c'est mon opinion
personnelle j'ai préféré les faux
tatouages le dollar américain moi c'est
mon opinion est que beaucoup plus de
budget que le rugby qui aura beaucoup
plus de ressources aussi le budget ça
donne pas des bonnes idées ça te fait
porter ça donne les moyens de réaliser
des choses que tu as peut-être pu
médecin sas a fait pâte à crêpes et du
génie et de ne rien l'argent tpiy même
ça pulse pas seulement tu peux de
complaire aux soins spa jetant l'argent
sur un problème réglé trop fort de quoi
de dommages et conseiller des micro
budget
quant à quoi a dit réputé des bons
acteurs peut-être mon matériel ça va
être vraiment probablement fait que les
budgets c'est une des raisons pourquoi
on découvre des nouveaux acteurs
c'est maintenant si tu as de l'argent ça
se peut que tu t'engages me gerols pour
jouer ton personnage de vieux d'un an
soixantaine qui comme soit un baume ou
soit un intellectuel c'était ça se peut
que tu bosses l'argent sur rémy girard
plus que ce n'est pas cet argent là tu
le met dans un acteur qui est fait
par un autre parcours complètement qui
lui charge pas mal moins chaud qui
accèdent au second
oui vraiment oui parce que ça fait que
tu découvres du nouveau monde qui est
intéressant chez oui les clubs ben ouais
si c'est parce que souvent justement des
films utilisant tous les producteurs
qu'ils acceptent de s'investir là dedans
parce qu'ils croient au projet ou croit
ou au real pitre en plus
soit des real ça marche avec quelqu'un
peut-être besoin d'une telle personne
pour un rôle bien tu vas passer à la
personne qui t'a et des outils am and is
normal que les métaux lourds est rendue
je pense que le droit de charger en même
temps je me tourne des films des
microbes des communes comme ça on est
payé on est moins payé que sur un projet
qui est 100 % financés mais quand tu dis
moi je trouve ça le fun l'idée de
justement de faire des projets avec 101
tels que je parle je crée pas un an
d'aidé pro bono mais logiquement ça se
peut pas mais médicaux projet puis que -
pour titre ccb normal ça votre venir je
pense pillés c'est d'encourager une
relève qui est donc je fais partie aussi
du fait que j'ai déjà une partie
j'imagine que tu es l'acting avant tout
c'est une passion pour toi le tue ah oui
c'est pas du tout je le vois pas comme
un bien sûr maintenant c'est ma job puis
justement ce jeu cette réalisation
laisse ces malades le testing la sphère
que j'aime le plus faire mettons et
c'est ce qu'ils paient injustement fini
c'est vraiment le fun mais ouais mais
c'est fou qui j'espère que ça va rester
comme ça parce qu'on nie mais on n'est
pas beaucoup et je suis c'est quand les
statistiques mais il y en a beaucoup des
acteurs qui doivent compenser mes
arrières j'espère que ça va rester comme
ça mais c'est qu'on disait autrefois
takata passion devient ton métier ce que
tu aimes bien en plus l'argent rentre
c'est comme qu'est ce que plus ça parce
qu'il ya beaucoup de gens qui ont la
passion dans la vie piqué notamment sont
obligés de travailler avoir une job de
joe arrivée tpiy et le cac tout arrive
ensemble le merveilleux
oui oui vraiment puis c'est tellement un
beau moi je regarde me tourne voir des
films faire des films parler avec les
gens de cinéma tj 6e ça rien à voir avec
jobs jobs c'est qu'on fait juste pour
l'argent l'environnement aussi stimulant
qui compte déjà intéressant pis ça le
faire grandir justement par les plateaux
de tournage totalement sortir de le
hachis bah oui complètement le sur le
plan humain qui est émotif pitt et
créatif c'est important mais moi je
crois vraiment que le cinéma noté les
influencent beaucoup de choses ça fait
si notre culture n'en fait pas vraiment
c'est la culture en continu sa télé tous
contre corps soit vraiment oui est ce
que j'allais déserté justement c'est
finalement au québec et on écoute à la
télévision en semble- t- on l'avait on
l'a encore m'étais peut-être avec
netflix a dit l'un nous référons devient
un peu plus américaine mais ton métier
la culture c'est noté c'est ce qu'ils
nous disent d'abord d'aider des
références culturelles communes en était
on peut faire une boucle de wattao prime
à la casse oui je sais ça rapproche un
peuple
j'avais fait mon choix et je réfléchis
ça
à la première émission tout le monde en
parle d'accord la première il y avait
invité israël
je pense que c'était la première saison
qui je me rappelle quand j'étais arrivé
à l'école que c'était le cours
d'histoire sont r2 veut dire que la
première saison c'était que je pense
qu'on leur dit
pour vrai
une chance qu'on a tout le monde en
parle en termes pour pour notre culture
collective
c'est vraiment important cette émission
parce que à chaque semaine on parle des
enjeux puis c'est nous on appartient
podcast parce qu'on voulait avoir des
conversations longue avec des gens
intéressants c'est tout le monde en
parle comme un hybride entre une
conversation plus longue puis une
entrevue de télé de base c'est que je
trouve qu'ici ça va dans la bonne
direction pour l'information de façon
wii et du montage mais c'est quand même
c'est quand même une longue conversation
tient à nuancer si on veut et je me
disais une chance qu'on eut donc on a
tout le monde en parle qu'on continue à
la voir et j'espère qu'on va l'avoir
encore longtemps parce que où que si ça
ça en vaut qu'on a quelque chose qui
ressemble à celui je trouve que
collectivement tout le monde y gagne
oui ça représente vraiment bien
l'actualité diversité ce total et des
bout'choux quelqu'un lundi matin qui
répond qui sait et pis ça fait qu'il ya
une réflexion aussi collective leur vie
à chaque semaine et c'est ça fait
réfléchir ça fait jaser et ce après six
années qui critique un peu de faux le
billet ou utiles anglais ou un outil
l'espèce de participer riz qui est
peut-être le matin on le dit que
certains se reconnaissent pour moi ça me
dérange pas moi je trouve que c'est une
belle émission pittis je trouve vraiment
qu'ils les invités sont attendus pis
d'un lieu qui dany font pas grand chose
pareille
tordons le cou guité et guerrier ben may
les invités qui font beaucoup de places
très fait que c'est pas comme si c'était
ultra contrôlé il y avait un message qui
avaient dissoutes et je trouve que quand
même les invités ils peuvent changer
puis arrivés avec leurs messages soient
moins puis c'est sûr qu'ils sont hautes
et j'ai imaginé que c'était difficile
d'avoir un animateur qui peut biaiser du
tout il a relaté le journal il n'en
concède qu'il avance est ce aussi le
teen mettons ici ont une haute opinion
jose situ c'est aussi le but on n'a pas
été impartial puis des troupes à
l'information comme c'est que les
nouvelles ce fut de l'information oui
mais toi d'ailleurs le talent et leur
récemment oui pis les l'expérience
baptiste et justement c'est stressant
parce qu'on sait que c'est vraiment un
côté épique ça fait 15 ans non en fait
c'est plus stressant qu'une autre
entrevue c'est parce que juste pour la
lampe la drogue comme un autre mais je
t'ai matin j'étais un peu moins stressés
ici ce matin un problème mais je sais
mais en fait c'est moins gros qu'est-ce
que ça en a l'air
le studio est plus petit sans comme plus
proche des gens juste en masse moyens
j'étais un petit peu plus rassurés mais
j'essaye de prendre une gorgée d'eau
entre les questions qu'ils avaient un
milk shake and patent d'après en
entrevue mais ça a été ça est très
contente c'est j'espère y retourner
une bonne les l'utilisation d'un statut
je pense d'autres femmes peut-être moins
pas cela comme une espèce de ses côtés
comme se battre j'imagine que je vois
dans la bonne direction
j'entends tout j'ai une question mais
qui m'est venue par rapport à tu parlais
tu parlais de kant sûreté d'un plateau
ça tu as menée sur 1 sur plein d'aspects
notamment l'aspect créatif
est-ce que tu
de ce fait d'autres formes d'art que
l'acteur jay de pain mais j'ai beaucoup
danser quand j'étais au secondaire
plus on dirait que je recommence à j'ai
repris les cours je suis des cours en
somalie
oui parce que justement à temps comme en
ce moment je tourne pas mais depuis il
faut apprendre à gérer son temps soi
même est ce que je suis capable de le
faire mais j'aime somme le victor ou 6
me dont il faut apprendre à se faire un
horaire cancer trust comprend que c'est
ça sinon j ouer j'écris j'écris j'ai
toujours écrit pour moi genre de dans
des cahiers j'ai un document dans mon
ordi d'entente et j'ai toujours fait ça
depuis que je suis petite pile
cette année je me suis j'ai une idée de
scénario andy qui m'est venu comme ça
que j'ai commencé à l'écrire
puis on a déposé à la cdec je le fais
avec qui n'envoie une amie à moi qui
réalisatrice qui s'appelle catherine
therrien
donc on a eu on a déposé l'année passée
la sodec ça peut fonctionner mais on
n'était pas très loin donc mon état
notre deuxième dépôt on va voir des
nouvelles ont mis le truc au loin puis
j'aime justement voir
à voir cette je sens que j'ai plus de
liberté peut-être quinze jours de
pouvoir avoir la ce que j'aime le plus
c'est jouer mais à un moment donné c'est
le fun ne pas être en attente d'un
réalisateur qui veut une loi ou de
savoir que c'est toi qui décide en fait
qui est à l'origine de quelque chose
acquiesce amacom vraiment nourrit je
dirais comme comme créatrice
j'espère qu'ils soient de la mort -
merci c'est grave mon premier débat
qu'on le sait ce qu'on a ici c'est
normal d'essayer plusieurs fois puis ce
processus mais aussi dans ton des
commentaires de réécrire de ça fait un
an maintenant que j'écris un homme
puisque un an puis ça tellement l'a
tellement évolué c'est un module et qui
se trouve sur un terrain c'est ça aussi
le la
la beauté de ce système le de
financement qui critiquent métier le
fait justement d'avoir des commentaires
ça fait qu'il ya ultime ans je peux pas
vraiment planté une impression que tu
passes à travers un système où faut
quand même qu'avec des gens qui approuve
un peu ce que tu fais pitié après sa
production petit ça ça peut faire un
film en claquant des doigts
il ya beaucoup de femmes mauvais que
faire des films pour zéro dès lors
facile martin beaupré métier avec un
téléphone mettons ce oui mais tout le
fait que le procès le long procès ils
ont tout le temps de penser de
retravailler dans les commentaires ça
fait qu'en bout de ligne
ton projet risque d'être bien fait car
nous aussi le fait que j'entends parler
justement des institutions puissent fait
de déposer un projet j'entends des gens
autour de moi mais moi mais ils donnent
des commentaires mais c'est qui eux pour
critiquer mon projet mais en même temps
tu sais pas ce qui s'est passé même si
c'est vrai que qui toi pour penser que
ton scénario parfait du monde qui font
ça depuis des années on a vu qu'ils
connaissent le fonctionnement
intrinsèque à un scénario à pré
production puis en post-production si
c'est des gens qui sont mieux qualifié
que nicole précieux droite mettre
d'accord sur mac certains commentaires
maintenant c'est subjectif et
commentaires constructifs et surtout le
prêt aux pôles
c'est toujours truc qualité d'être
capable de prendre des commentaires
constructifs le team is a peut être
bénéficié de ce désagrément
oui mais qu'il adore travailler beaucoup
scénario la wii qui est ce que est ce
que tu peux en parler un peu ou ou tu
veux tu préfère garder ce
je pense havas sports piscine on s'est
dit et story 5
je pense qu'ils ne demandent pas
beaucoup de moyens excuses - huis clos
ça se passe presque tout dans un short à
queue on s'est dit qu'on le ferait
probablement quand même et puis de voir
des exemples comme d'aider des gens qui
en font des films 500 beaucoup d'argent
mais ça encourage ou cia porter goss cas
pas besoin d un petit toit probablement
avec avec le réseau de contacts que tu
t'es fait si ce qui est quand même voie
que toi tu veux t'impliquer dans un
projet pour pratiquement rien vous c'est
un peu un gage de
tu peux devenue un gage de qualité
peut-être pour les gentils c'est
quelqu'un qui est inconnu dit à moi je
fais ce parent directeur photo sur mon
projet pour 1200 pièces pour le geek au
complet il voit tout le monde sinon mais
toi probablement qui étaient déjà les
espèces de gage de savon au moins ça va
être vu oui peut-être plus c'est vrai
oui peut-être que c'est encourageant
pour eux pour les gens qui travaillent
là dessus
oui parce que maintenant c'est ça coûte
plus petit en disant on peut pas faire
un film pour des pinottes l'on peut on
peut quand même en faire pour pas grand
chose avec les mouvements qui disponible
un whist un ami qui passait qui fait la
colle ou tu auras de s'en sortir
puis pascal ses moutons pour son film je
pense que avec les avec le budget qu'il
ya eu ou des jeunes réalisateurs qui ont
maintenant le micro budget mais c'est
des gens justement qui prennent le
budget mais qui est plein de choses
aussi qui doivent qui on peut payer
nécessairement partie se fait d antan
depuis trente ans je travaille avec tout
type arcade avant de faire ce fameux
levier fait des films avec encore moins
de budget qui est habitué à à rien plus
avec les fallait bosser avec des
brouillards t'choupi fac ça c'est juste
transposer y ait pu faire plus pour les
faux tatouages mais il n'était pas
établi
manière le son prochain film de genre de
millions en fait oui il va tourner cet
été justement son fils inquiet il faut
là aussi c'est vrai ça sûrement aller se
[ __ ] sur le plateau comme vous
l'écrivez c'est la crise en plus d'une
en jeu et le chp aussi choisir celle qui
met ses yeux il est une actrice
allemande et non
le soulier auditionné il a choisi fait
que voir un vrai film sur des vraies
dangereuse on est piégé
puis toutes les deux soucis de tupi
toute la psychologie parce que tu vises
adp qui est plus complexe que juste
qu'on voit maintenant will vision neutre
du point de vue de l'athlète cesser
une business comment ça marche plus il a
pris une fois que c'est fini
c'est une expérience de cela
à comprendre le style extérieur de
l'extérieur le ticket un athlète
olympique c'est comme tcc comme parfait
d'un point de vue non s'exerçait moi
c'est mes dix mois et puis la complexité
quand même attaqué assez riquet la rade
cool c'est quoi c'est quoi les prochains
projets sur lesquels tu veux tu vas
travailler
ben je tourne clash la série quotidienne
dont je parlais tantôt mots que je vais
faire une bonne partie - mais c'est en
fait c'est un mois et demi après ces
semaines ci faisait ou c'est sovac tv ça
s'adresse à un public à faire des séries
originales
oui oui oui je n'ai entendu que les
branches qui voulaient arrêter un peu
sur les quais mais messi continue tant
mieux je pense - ben nous on a notre
deuxième saison donc je l'enverrai
commença son vrai talent on sait que
j'avais entendu mais tant mieux si oui
c'est ce fait que c'est bien c'est bien
plaisant c'est aussi comparé du rythme
tantôt mais on dirait que c'est aussi un
c'est une façon d'être
faut que tu travailles vite faut que ce
soit un choix rigoureux avec moi j'aime
bien c'est comme une espèce de
gymnastique et le camp d'entraînement
des points exactement ça va être ça va
être cool pleut ça fait un petit bout
que j'ai pas tourné fait que j'ai
vraiment de me remettre puis sinon c'est
le film de mon amie et une gallois puis
christophe lebas qui s'appelle la marina
avec si le film pour lequel ils ont
émigré au budget de téléfilms comme non
suin une bande de jeunes qui travaillent
dans une marina elle était lé personnage
principal c'est rémi goulet puis comme
une histoire sportive de wakeboard un
peu sous jacentes
mais sinon c'est aussi un film sur le
être un emprunt peut le
l'adolescence et l'âge adulte du billet
cette période un peu flou moi je pense à
jean le vieux comme innovate contre 14
en mettant vie un autre
qu'est ce que je fais cinq ans comme une
ado encore les adultes non non non plus
j'ai comme l'impression que ce qui est
probablement mettons mais mes neveux
nièces une boîte immédiate et l'adulte
et lui met au même niveau goût je
mettais mes tempes maison quand je t'ai
dit oui à laver stage le team et et
aucune des copains j'ai rien fait de
grave
non je fais de scam avancé qu'elle se
hisse au sommet comme on dirait que
l'idée préconçue qu'on avait des adultes
j'ai pas l'impression que je vais y
arriver non plus oui le fils aîné comme
total et un petit enfant intérieur qui
irait selon un peu ce qu'est ce qu'on
fait jamais vraiment certain que s'il
n'y a pas de plan de mal à les compléter
mais en même temps tant mieux c'est plus
excitante
non seulement les enfants car ça va
cogner mes parents et la france allaient
déboucher quatrième c'est comme c'est de
l'impro loin
cd peut-être que en fait moi
l'impression que j'avais quand j'étais
plus jeune des adultes jeux les jeux
l'un peut présentement avec quelques
jeunes mes amis puisque lyon comme une
job c'était pour le reste de leur vie
voire une bague correcte et pis ils
mettront une maison qui le sont comme
installer pour un bout de ces mois mais
temps long
on ne peut renouveler notre bail on
s'envoie dans deux mois puis j'ai pas
d'autre place à vivre encore c'est que
je me disais pas société on dirait que
j'ai moins parce que je les place un peu
comme je plaçais des adultes quand
j'étais plus jeune oui mais les gens de
mon entourage
c'est peut-être des gens je suppose y
ait des gens qui ont nounou travail j'ai
l'impression d'un quotidien et plus au
jour le jour
dan bigras modeler journée ne se
ressemblent potes et peut-être qu'ils
entonnent jobs a même place à tous les
matins mais moi je sais pas peut-être
que ça te pose tinto 3 5 - nancy
enfin ma maison si bon ben vous restez
maître une hypothèque piché que dans
trois ans
cependant je fais panama me retrouverais
pas avec laquelle j'ai pas de casting
carole pire ennemi plus vieillissant
mais tant qu'on
en mettant quelques uns je rentrais tu
t'amuses éclaté à 17 ans
je connaissais rien en musique que je
tape à bomber ce métier tu dire j'ai 17
ans j'ai le temps tous les grades rendre
à 27,10 qui bon jeu rendues le sais ça
fait maintenant dix ans je fais ce
c'est comme en savoir plus
un espèce d'aperçu sûr ça va être quoi
ta vie ou baptise pendant que ta vie
mais où je rends du petit c'est comme le
bon la trentaine approche fait que leur
faudrait qu'ils aient comme les choses
il faudrait que ça marche parce que 800
places et qu'en plus ça avance - je vois
ma vie comme définitive de partie des
possibilités c'est comme plus moelleux
et commence à avoir le temps presse
oui fakir et ben angoisse tout ça
comprend oui ouais ouais mais les choix
texas comme ça serait très s'il était
fait des choix de vie c'est la vie ça ne
serait pas forcément de sens non non et
c'est passé ce temps j'ai fêté mes temps
c'est comme si on était
costes ont dû si mal qui durcit piqué
comment ta mort comme les semailles et
dur complètement non mais c'est
maintenant le jeu tama un enfant mais
beau mot de licenciement plus savoureux
plus de 6 pi rada 50 ans b est à moitié
durci oui comme j'espère que comme aucun
contrôle sur les cinquante années
derrière toiles sont figés ils bougeront
plus de contrôles où tu t'en veux mais
tu es quand même proportionnellement cet
avis de moins en moins de contrôles sur
l'ensemble de ta vie ouais pistes a
ajouté c'est comme si en même temps
c'est tout là c'est l'âge où la lutte
est la décennie où on fait les choix lié
les grands choix qui vont quand même
donné un résultat qu'on veut avec lequel
on veut vivre pendant les raisonner de
vie mais c'est aussi la décennie où on
est comme dans un mode on peut avoir du
fun
puis j'ai les crocs il se sert et que
c'est ben condensé je trouve peut-être
qu'on va se sentir comme ça je sais pas
peut-être que dans chaque décennie on va
se sentir de la même façon et à la
décennie de la trentaine la fameuse
décennies un tj j'ai pas si on veut
amener avoir une pause depuis faire
comme à bon ça c'est fait le jeu c'est
réglé tout est réglé je sais pas entre
autres qu'on arrive à qui je parle comme
un étudiant arrivé à 20 places
nécessaires potes phil darwin
non j'ai pas se la jouer dans vide
n'arrive pas qu'à mâchoire d'un club
enfin quand c'est terminé fini exacte du
carnage continue jusqu'à fin mai
oui un drôle de savoir le concept mais
en même temps moi j'ai vraiment
l'impression piste un peu sur ce sur
quoi je travaille en ce moment je n'ai
juste pas pensé à ça
c'est la question tu te vois ou dans 5 m
c'est difficile à répondre parce que
mettons pour moi je pourrais je pourrais
dire je me dis je pourrais raconter un
rêve que j'ai été pendant cinq ans
maintenant j'aimerais ça avoir publié
les vous quoi que ce soit at il raconté
ce rêve là mais de dire tu vaux dans ces
cas on dirait que ça minimise
l'importance de des opportunités qui se
présentent à toi ouais c'est
principalement pour tous hâtive le
troisième étant de ce petit mot dans
cinq ans peut-être que tu te serais vue
ou est ce que tu es maintenant c'est où
peut-être que mai
une opportunité qui se présente à toi va
peut-être tout changer oui complètement
c'est moi même temps avant de faire
occupation double sujet
tout passe par ce prix c'est coulthard
mieux je sais pas si j'aurais pu me voir
une place dans cinq ans mais en même
temps d'accepter le fait qu'une
expérience comme se présente de la
saisir
puis de d'aller dans cette direction là
même c'est pas la direction dans
laquelle je m'en allais est quelque
chose de beau danseur parce que ça fait
90 degrés oui c'est un jeune davis a
complètement dévié ou est-ce que mon
cheminement qui arrêtait continue-t-il
c'est d'accepter ce genre de truc club
de hockey mais le ce projet l'homme est
présenté ce projet m'intéresse
est-ce que ça me fait quitter l'objectif
des yeux oui est ce que j'en ai un autre
au bout de ce chemin là oui mais prenons
le train puis je pense que si tu gagnes
c'est cette espèce d'ouverte sur lot
quotidien moi je travaille là-dessus
justement paul pourqué ces deux
d'assouplir la réserve d'assouplir le
désir d'arriver comme on dit a pas de
fil d'arrivée faite visant pas un aussi
un fils et moi c'est ça il y en a si on
considère qu'un 1-1 là-bas y en a mille
autres au tournant et fini d'autres
autos affecté d'assouplir justement à la
rigidité qu'on se met par rapport à aux
attentes de la société envers envers
nous voyez pas important
fx et ça c'est juste c'est juste un
raisonnement que j'essaie de changer au
petit bal en centrant son destin en main
parce qu'à manille personne qui va forte
que toi tu écris ton scénario titane à
peu près personne c'est même si de les
importuner qui viennent d'y être ouvert
à alain privé qui a trouvé comme ceux
qui j'ai eu la réflexion quand j'ai 28
ans j'ai 28 ans janvier puis c'est un
peu cela me suis dit jeudi le 30 et
bientôt les piles 30 dans la conception
que j'avais avant c'était de me dire
c'était pas fait quelque chose à 30 ans
ça sent une tortue et mettons en temps
j'ai le temps de rarement parler d'un
artiste qui sort son premier album à 30
ans ils le salissent souvent les
grillons intégrer dans leur vin de notre
pression sans lever parce que sinon tu
fis je pense puis faudra peut-être pas
justement sortir ma tombe toujours aussi
jean marc vallée crazy le temps une
crise de la quarantaine le pays faisait
il faisait des trucs mais si le débit
peut pister de soda fabriquer des farc
marxistes et piscicoles oui pilotes
préférés
c'est vraiment bon moi j'ai toujours dit
ce qu'il avait à faire écouter
maintenant quelqu'un arrive au québec
qui dit ok de moelleux de moi un album
puis un film à écouter pour comme le
québec veut dire crazy le dire le don ah
ouais d'accord avec ce que tu veux tu
peux comprendre un petit peu oui c'est
vrai donc vous êtes doit combat parce
que dit il
crazy c'est vraiment le québec est il
qu'avec des années soixante dix le
québec comme ans qui a été fondateur
pour nous laitiers pour tout le monde
c'est vraiment une plaque tournante puis
l'important montrer ce c'est
j'approuvais de choix tue d'inventer
dans tes rêves de jouer vraiment ça je l
aime vraiment beaucoup café de flore
aussi sans réellement bon c'est fait
avec la musique quand j'ai bien aimé sa
série ici ouais avec moi je reste dans
mes réalisateurs
si je peux être avec lui le message est
lancé mais oui tu pas de la musique qui
vraiment
il une seule raison la musique petit
vocal augustin clairement mélomanes oui
oui compétition geek ultime la musique
oui mais où city stories steiner choisir
la bonne touche au bon moment mais si ça
pète chizy une toune aussi avec un
montage le tessin visiteurs de bon goût
le ça ajoute vraiment oui c'est des
choses surprenantes et s est pas quelque
chose qui peut qui convenu
nécessairement des fois j'ai
l'impression que je ne sais pas s'ils
planifient revenir au québec pour me
faire une production
québec les acteurs québécois en france
est ce que il ya peu de son dernier mot
en français
j'espère que non mais j'espère vraiment
que - denis villeneuve sera la même
chose si ces deux là je me dis j'espère
vraiment qu'ils vont venir faire quelque
chose si c'est tellement ça vaut
tellement cher pour la culture sont trop
attachés au québec aussi positif à la
décision consciente de peace analyste
areva l'état les tournées aux petits
venus tourner oui c'est vrai cette
équipe a au québec les genres amag
n'aurai pas ma gueule mais c'est une
place de moins meurtri oui puis fait
tout ça je pense qu'ils font ici m'a
semblé deux facs et fait travailler
demandera ben oui mais ça monte je
trouve qu'il y aura encore un
attachement qui sont pas juste ma vie de
mon rêve américain
on sent pas que c'est ça leur nom leur
approche l'attitude de georges conduit
non je pense que ça non plus hein
par contre
admettons tout juste les clés
d'hollywood
c'est auch de dire s'étoffe de passer de
dire je peux prendre les acteurs que je
veux vous avec le budget que je veux
laisser ce valais avec dallas buyers
club n'a gagné le meilleur acteur mais
acteur de soutien
tout le monde veut travailler avec toi
lui en a pas un qui va dire non je peux
être dans un film de jean marc vallée
fait que tu dis
j'ai infinie de budget je peux prendre
qui je veux avec les tanks avec le temps
que je veux certains disent ils de dire
je vois maintenant une pause sur ce
pendant deux ans puis je vais revenir
faire un projet de plus petites en
plastique sera pas vu à l'international
oui je sais pas je sais pas c'est quoi
en même temps at il ajouté l'argent veut
clairement pu résorber ces gens-là
effectué ce point facteurs l'avenir nous
dira oui mais j'espère que vient je
commence à shooter y est de ne pas voter
[Rires]
oui ouais gros ça va mieux
d'ailleurs les postes la page les poches
une c'est pas moi j'ai vu juste la ley
le vieux c'est tellement dommage non
c'est vraiment bon mais il ya tellement
de films dans wii
j'écoute beaucoup de films ben oui mais
pas suffisamment on dresse et ainsi
jusqu'à maintenant j'essaie de voir les
trucs québécois qui sortent mais il
faudrait que j'aille plus au cinéma jeu
à la base une cinéphile mais moins
active
c'est cyclique des fois ouais vraiment
ses rangs le monde qui compte deux
femmes par soir à toulouse
oui c'est ça c'est cette offre et pascal
plancque qui vient d'annoncer il coûte
toujours toujours toujours des faits
mieux tout vu pee wee
parce qu'avec le la danse c'est comme ça
c'est maintenant la discussion serait
gpo it montant caf et ça me faisait
partie d'un texte est illégal
ça fait toujours pas dit à moi je t'aime
que tout est fait par ces médias chaque
fois que je le vois tu es juste comme un
master class à chaque fois que j'écoute
le de ski sortie tony blair
les ports world et la musique aussi de
seppi il me faire des top teams forêt
oui aux 50 albums mon top 50 films fac
est excité bonnes suggestions tout
autant le voir mais aussi identifier les
choses le titre que oui un esprit
d'analysé que ton album numéro 4 de 2010
bon merci quoi juste pour le monde si
qui peut-être de canesse peau d'un quoi
on peut on peut voir maintenant j'ai
parlé mais oui on regarde quoi les
monstres qui est disponible sur tou.tv
au moment d'aller chez qui s'appauvrit
merci
deux tours saint piat je pense une série
importante où ces points sont gênantes
être sans vouloir passer pendant 15
minutes mais je trouve que c'est
vraiment bien
[Musique]
bien montrer comment l'escaladé d'une
relation comme ceux s'installe parce que
des fois t on au vu du monde violent
cinéma métiers des foyers juste dit a
lancé le disque et l'on voit tout les
petits mécanismes ni les mêmes tactiques
la manipulation pour arriver le oui
choque est quelqu'un qui qui qui
d'inspiration comme ceux où quelqu'un
que jamais vécu ce qu'ils voient si ça
va permettre de le reconnaître d'avoir
plus facilement
c'est facile aussi de juger tu me donnes
ton histoire des fois petit dit voyons
la fille que ma niaiseuse de retourner
avec le même nom le 6e temps pas feinte
et piqué mais non c'est beaucoup plus
complexe que ça puis je trouve la série
explique bien aussi des deux côtés
comment comment c'est possible de
devenir une victime alors que tu es une
fille super indh qui je pars bientôt qui
est qui et confites et sûre d'elle et
qui se fait complètement avoir par un un
bourg où le timbre maître de la
manipulation des fêtes voilà le monstre
puis avant qu'on explose sinon on ne
parle et qui tous les mensonges sc2
registre avec 220 euros et coups de lame
en cela par c'est pourtant remonté le
moral
exact parfait et merci beaucoup